all right chris
chris where'd you grow up where are you
from originally uh
i was born in portsmouth virginia
i grew up in a place called fall river
massachusetts
how would you describe your childhood
it was uh it was okay when i was a lot
younger
uh
maybe until i was five six years old my
parents got divorced
and my mother you know started seeing
these different men
and uh she got remarried
to abusive uh
it was abusive uh relationship you know
i remember and uh they used to go out
drinking a lot and come home and
my
stepfather at the time you know
he'll take all his anger out on me you
know
and
that caused me to keep running away from
home
and so i turned to the streets at a very
young age
started getting into
selling drugs at a young age and then at
15 i was finding myself with a needle in
my arm shooting heroin
this was all in boston yes
and so
i was constantly in and out of jail
you know in and out of county growing up
i dropped out of school
uh my dad he thought it was wise for me
to go work on a fishing boat
if i didn't want to go to school that's
what i had to do
and so i did that and he regrets it
because at that age i was making a lot
of money and i also turned into a heroin
addict
there's a lot of drugs on the fishing
boats right yes there is
and uh so at that age i was working with
grown men
and so i grew up pretty quick
and i learned a lot about life at a
young age
how far did you go to school uh i
dropped out in my freshman year
and after after uh
the fishing
jobs you
how long do you do that i did that for
about five years
and it's uh you know you work in seasons
so it wasn't like a total of five years
it was seasons right when you weren't
working five seasons i was going out
three months at a time when you weren't
out in the water where were you were you
up to i was skeleton
you know
so
uh
i i just every time i came into shore i
had a pocket full of money
and i didn't know what else to do with
it but go to strip clubs and
get high get drunk
and uh i never really had any good role
models in my life growing up you know
i uh i so i just turned to the streets
at a very young age
started getting in trouble with the law
been in prison
i've seen a lot of a lot of a lot of bad
stuff happening
how old are you now uh right now i'm all
40 you're 40.
and uh
yeah
uh since i mean
my life constantly gets worse and worse
and worse it seems like as i get older
just last year i've gotten stabbed three
times in hollywood
you know uh i've been shot at
i was never in gangs
i always hung out hung around them
people that were affiliated
uh
hung around with a lot of uh organized
crime
growing up yeah in boston there's a lot
of that you know
so
uh
i got really close friends that uh
you know they know whitey
whitey bojo
so
growing up he was a big influence in my
life
you know
i looked up to him
so
heroin has been part of your life yes
all along uh well i got about three
years clean now off heroin
but
you know
i'm battling with other addictions
nope not fentanyl
i've done fentanyl a couple times out
here and each time i od'd
flatline dead you know
and
there was two times where i was so
pissed off that they brought me back at
the hospital i went out
got the same fentanyl and i'll do it
again like i wanted to die
really
you know because the life out here in
the streets
it's definitely not fun it's no picnic
especially when you're not from
california
you know what is your drug now
my drone is crystal meth christmas
and uh hookers
would you call yourself a sex addict as
well absolutely yeah
absolutely
uh
i've never uh really had sex for money
but to get high
you know so so the the drug addiction
drives the
sex addiction you think yes absolutely
uh crystal meth will do that to some
people yeah
i uh i've gotten paid to
make movies
and uh
you know
i i've grown up doing a lot of ecstasy
special k
i was into clubs raves
and it's got me nowhere you know in life
so you say sex for money you're you're
also making money
i was i was uh
pretty much i guess escorting myself
right
you know this is with the male clients
or no female clients
yeah so women women will pay you for yes
yes that's a lot of guys fantasy i think
yeah but uh these women weren't always
dying pieces either you know
i just had an addiction to feed all the
time
so the money would pay for your drugs
yes and i also had a gambling addiction
was it right yes i like to gamble
and uh every day on these streets out
here i gambled my life
you know
and it's like it's kind of an addiction
the lifestyle you know
because i lived it for so long
the danger of living down here yes
it's just
i don't enjoy it
but
i don't enjoy the danger but i enjoy the
everyday living of it
you know because you don't know what
you're going to get into you don't know
what's going to happen
it's just about taking chances yeah the
adrenaline yes and uh
so i did the recovery thing down in
delray beach florida
and
with that
that brought me into a different world i
was clean for a little bit
but i could never stay clean for more
than a year
and what happened
was uh
i was just in and out of flop houses
which are sober houses that you don't
really have to be sober to be there just
having an insurance policy
and as long as you have that insurance
policy you could stay
but once it runs out they're kicking you
out
and uh they're just called flop houses
and they're all over delray beach
and so
i've been in several of those i worked
for treatment
while using drugs
uh
i've
i mean i did the whole insurance thing
of getting people insurance policies
and
you know cashing them in
you know
and so
that i was doing that i was doing a lot
of telemarketing
uh i got hit by a car
in papua new beach florida
and got a rod put on my right leg
and so that right there gave me the
green light the pass to get oxycoding
so i was going to different pain clinics
all through florida
each day
and getting pills and i was selling them
well i sold pills to a confidential
informant
which landed me in prison
my first offer was 30 years
i got a lawyer and i beat that the
reason why i was 30 years was because it
was armed trafficking
my co-defendant
confessed up to the pistol charge and i
took the pill charge
and that's what got me three years
oh
just all my life it's been nothing but
chaos
running from the cops running from the
law
uh i just could never seem to get it
right
as much as i do want to
and try i just something always gets in
the way and i just fall
what do you suspect the
the core of that is what what the cost
well first of all it's got something to
do my mentality
the way i carry myself
uh
my addiction
uh it's not easy being an addict and
being homeless yeah you know the
homelessness makes it stressful yes
and there's times where i choose to get
high then eat food you know i'll be so
hungry
i just rather get high because it numbs
everything
for me you know
it takes me out of my body you know
and then whether it's a sex addiction
gambling addiction drug addiction
it's all the same yes it's all the same
and so
i remember when i was 14 years old
i was just coming home from school
and my neighbor which was my best
childhood friend
had shot himself
uh that played a big part in my life you
know
i
to this day i remember hearing the
gunshots
you died yes
it was intentional yes
he left a note
to his family
and
you know that played a big part of my
life because you know me and him we grew
up to with each other we played little
league hockey
you know
we just did childhood
what kids do right and the kids you know
and so
i it's just
all grown up it's just being in and out
of county and out of county
you know how much prison time have you
done in your life well i've been to
prison twice
but i've been i did a lot of county time
i uh
so jail in prison yeah
and so
yeah
uh today i'm just trying to
you know
pick up my life
which
is going okay now
i'm doing a lot better with a lot of
things in my life
i'm learning how to deal with a lot of
[ __ ]
without having to use violence
uh when i was growing up i had a really
bad temper
i was always getting into fights
uh i had
you know issues with the cops
i never got along with the law
i uh i
worked for a lot of underground gambling
spots
you know
i remember you know
being
12 years old
i got handed a bag
and said do not open it and i had a lock
on it
and this was my first assignment
and i didn't realize what was going on
at that age i was just told to bring it
to somebody to not open it
and i'll get paid
and so i did
and so
with that being said i got paid five
grand
but that five grand came with a lot of
a lot of other [ __ ] that i had to do
you know
so
i uh
it was a lifestyle i couldn't get out of
as much as i tried so what i did was i
kept running away
from my home area
so that way i could escape from that
life this is this is the mob related
stuff yes in boston and so
every time i went back home to visit
family i'll get
drug right back in
got my ass
beat have sit downs
and
at that time
my uncle and my aunt
they're in a motorcycle gang
and so i would always get into trouble
and have these sit downs with these
bikers
get slapped around a few times
and uh that was my punishment for every
time i got into trouble when i was
younger
and
you know
i uh
i didn't know nothing about crystal meth
i came out here to california
back home it was just all about heroin
and fentanyl
that's in oxies
roxies
which is why you know i went to prison
uh
i uh i was really bad with opiates
really bad
i just didn't know what to do
anymore i thought that was gonna turn
out to be my life
that i would have to depend on
every day being dope sick how am i gonna
get it
you know
that's definitely something i do not
miss
did crystal meth helped you get off of
heroin
uh crystal meth i didn't do crystal
method i came out here to california
uh no i uh i got off heroin through the
methadone clinic
back home
and then i got when i got into my
accident
i got a rod put on my right leg
i was prescribed
oxycodeine
down in florida
and i was going to all the pain clinics
different ones each each day
with my mri paperwork
and to write me out a script
so i was making all these i was getting
all these pills dilaudids oxies roxies
and i'll sell them
well how i went to prison was i uh
i sold pills to a confidential informant
which was a friend of mine's girlfriend
and she set me up
landed me in prison
so i did my time
and uh
you know the first offer was 30 years
i was they weren't coming off it
until my co-defendant took the pistol
charge
and i took the pill charge
and he got five
and i got three and a half
times earth you know
uh what emotions do you go through
i've always been depressed as a kid
growing up
so i and i'm still dealing with a lot of
depression
uh
at times i don't care if i live or die
because i don't know how to live
like a normal human being you know
what i consider living
most people want it you know
and uh
i've always just wanted to try to live
like a human being
and just have a chance
and
i was just never really given an
opportunity
you know
i uh
for the longest i've been trying to get
a hold of my son
he's 18 right now
and i can't get a hold of him
and it hurts you know
it really does
because every time i go to contact a
mother
she won't tell me nothing
have you been in your son's life
i was when he was younger
but as soon as i started getting locked
up and going to prison and
you know living the life of a drug
addict
that that all stopped
and uh
growing up you know
it was always about my dad coming to
pick me and my sister up for the
weekends
for visitation and being dropped off on
a sunday night well that sunday night
was the beginning of hell for the week
because by that time my mother would be
drunk
either getting beat up by her boyfriend
or husband
at the time
and that's what had me at a young age
start running away
from home
and turning to the streets
do you think that that childhood
environment that you grew up with kind
of set the tone for everything you're
going through now yes yeah
um i i've been to a lot of different
states
did a lot of traveling lived on the
streets in a lot of different states
from florida texas to jersey to new york
you know out here in california
san diego
hollywood
uh
you know i've even been up to
you know the mountains
and no matter where i go
i bring myself
and i gotta realize that
you know wherever i go i'm gonna always
be there
i can't run from me
and it's taken me all these years to
realize that
do you have regrets in your life i have
a lot of regrets
a lot of them
you know
a lot of them
for example
one of them would be
not being there so much for my son
as she's grown up
uh
to not
being there so much for my family
as they needed me
you know being there for my sister
as she's grown up
oh
i just
i've always felt horrible
and
all this guilt built up inside me
where it just
drugs made it so much better for me
you know it numb me
but i was always temporary
so i just always had to continue getting
high getting high getting high and by
all means i needed to get high i'd get
high
does it getting high give you an escape
from
yes and it makes me it makes me more
socially so sociable
uh
it makes me
at ease
a little bit
uh i deal with a lot of depression so
it helps my depression a lot
uh
i just
the life
that i've been living over the years
it's not a life for anybody
you know
i mean i've since been out here in
california
i've been stabbed been shot at
you know
all just for being in the wrong places
at the wrong time
you know
oh
i've always had this passion on you know
being a producer and making beats
and it's just i used to go to the studio
all the time just to hang out and just
to
learn and
you know once you know family members
found out what i was doing who i was
hanging out with
they put a stop to that you know
but that's what what they don't know is
that that's what kept me out of trouble
most of the time
and so
i lost that passion
you know
i was very athletic growing up
i was playing baseball on ice hockey
i've been on an all-star team quite a
few times for baseball
been a lot of tournaments for hockey
uh in canada montreal
uh
i
it's crazy i used to run away from home
i did this like three times
and joined carnivals
really and travel state to state
and living on the road you know so you
were a carney for a while yes
and that's the kind of excitement
that i like
you know
and this was back in the 90s
you know you don't see too much of that
these days right
and the drug
the drug addiction goes hand in hand
with that lifestyle yes
yes i mean
those times where you know i'll be on
the road hanging out at truck stops you
know
just trying to get to the next state
because i know that's where there's
gonna be a big carnival
and i needed to get there to work
so i'd get rides by truckers
i'd hitchhike
you know
uh i've been to a lot of states
my goal is to actually go to all 50
states
you know
what's been the craziest thing you've
gone through in your
the craziest lighting in the streets
me getting stabbed
i was uh i got stabbed over i don't know
on sunset by the triangle
and
i just remember my shirt was turning red
in my intestines
and my insides just hanging out and me
going up to cars at the light banging on
the windows asking for help
and they were just driving around me
you know like i didn't exist
and i guess i got found
on sunset boulevard
pretty much dead
you know
i just remember waking up in the
hospital
not really knowing what happened
and
i was told what happened
and i was told i was stitched up
that i was gonna be okay
i flipped out
i said i'm in a lot of pain i need some
morphine
right now
and they want to give it to me
so i demolished the whole room
of the emergency room
the cops came restraining me
and
i got my morphine
after all
and here i go again back on the pills
started doing heroin again
and
you know
it's just not a life for anybody
it really isn't
what do you uh what do you worry about
what are you afraid of
uh
living
you know i i don't know how to live
normal
i've seen so much and been through so
much and dealt with so many different
personalities
i just
i can't trust nobody
trust is a very big issue with me
uh
i just
my past haunts me all the time
when i close my eyes at night
i can't sleep
you know
i just i think about my life too much
i just
because i don't know
when i'm gonna go
when it's gonna be my time
you know
it's like
uh
as much as i try to do right
something just pulls me down
you know
oh
i really want to change but i just don't
know how
do you feel like you're self-destructive
absolutely
absolutely
and i just feel like
i have to accept this life
you know
and i've accepted it a long time ago
i came
you know
to believe that
there is no change in me
i could i could
move to a different state i've tried
that several times
i bring myself wherever i go
you know
i think the happiest time in my life was
when i first got off heroin
i was living in a halfway house
in florida
and
what happened was
uh i became a halfway house manager i
was doing good i relapsed long story
short i ended up back on the streets
well how i came out to california was
through a friend of mine
his name's billy and he got me into a
program
told me i needed to get out of
florida come here he's you know he'll
have everything set up what you did
well i went to that program
and started working for the place
as a
worker
and it got raided by the feds they're
doing body brokering
and uh insurance fraud
and so that left me on the streets
of uh
la
and i've been on the streets
ever since on and off
i just got approved for my housing
i'm looking to go back to school
and just to try to change my life
that's great
chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you learned in all of
this
can't trust everybody
just because they said they're riding
with you and they're having you back
most of the time
they're just talking [ __ ]
you know
nobody's going to be there for you
like your family will
you know
and i i never really understood that
when i was younger
you know
all right chris thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
out there thank you thank you very much
you